A really nice customization as well of these materials is to actually sort the parameters
and keep things organized into parameter groups.
So we can control the order in which information is displayed.
So instead of a generic expandable rollout, we can create a specific group for the various
defined parameters and sort it any way you see fit.
So we can select a node and add it to a group, which we'll do in the editor right now, and
set the sorting parameter and groups are sorted alphabetically.
So you can force them into a particular order by adding a numerical value.
So let's go ahead and do that.
And let's sort our albedo, metallic, roughness, and normal into their own groups here.
So back in our editor here, we will first do the albedo texture sorting group.
We can just type in one albedo and do sort priority as one here.
And then maybe let's do tint color.
We use a drop down and now we can select albedo because we had it typed in before.
Now let's do two there.
And then we'll do the same for metallic.
So we'll type in two dash metallic.
We'll do three dash roughness.
You can probably guess where we're going with the normal.
So four dash normal.
Save this.
And then we can see our groups here and we can see the tint colors below the texture
because we did the sort priority.
I didn't set any sort priorities for these other properties here, but you can obviously
do so depending on the complexity of your material there.
So really nice way to keep things organized and categorized.